bei mir zu gast arbeitsminister hubertus
heil wir haben gerade die neuesten
ermittlungen zum fall maddie gesehen sie
sind selbst vater wie nahe geht ihnen
das ich finde es schon bedrückend und
berührend und jeden fall noch erinnern
die eltern sehr lange selbst unter
verdacht gestanden das muss unerträglich
gewesen sein
und das nach all den jahren
offensichtliches ermittlungsergebnisse
gibt es kein trost sein verlust einer
tochter aber gibt den eltern wenigstens
ein stück gewissheit also ich kann mir
solche bilder ehrlich gesagt kann ich
kaum noch ansehen und seit ich kinder ab
und finde es sehr bedrückend
dreijähriges kind damals offensichtlich
ermordet worden
wie muss man sich das in der politik
vorstellen wenn solche meldungen
reinkommen diskutiert man dann im
kabinett mit misten minister kollegen so
genau so wie man das unter nachbarn von
euch tut ja klar wir sind ja alle keine
eisklötze sondern menschen aus fleisch
und blut
mütter und väter und natürlich redet man
auch unter den kollegen darüber nicht in
offiziellen sitzung aber auch am rand
und deshalb glaube ich viel bewegt neben
dieser anmeldung die es dann gestern
gegeben hat grosses thema heute
natürlich das konjunkturpaket 130
milliarden euro können sie sich
eigentlich ausmalen im kopf können sie
diese summen noch irgendwie greifen
es sind auf den ersten blick
atemberaubende summen wenn man auch noch
dazu zählt dass wir schon auch viel
gemacht haben zum beispiel der
kurzarbeit beschäftigung gesichert
aber ich finde es richtig dass jetzt zu
tun denn die alternativen ist nichts zu
tun müssen hierzu zu gucken wo
wirtschaftliche substanz verlieren wir
unternehmen kaputt gehen wie wir
arbeitsplätze verlieren und das wäre ein
teurer preis ist es richtig dass jetzt
zu tun die wirtschaft wieder anzukurbeln
für investitionen und kaufkraft zu
sorgen deshalb bin ich froh dass das
gestern gelungen ist sie sind
arbeitsminister das heißt sie haben den
blick auf die jobs wie viele jobs werden
durch dieses paket gesichert
das kann man nicht auf einen berechnen
das wäre unseriös
aber klar ist wir können nicht für jeden
arbeitsplatz trotz dieser maßnahmen
garantieren aber wir können um jeden
arbeitsplatz und wo ich viel wert darauf
lege auch jeden ausbildungsplatz kämpfen
wir haben jetzt dieser akutphase hinter
uns das heißt wir haben millionen von
jobs gesichert über kurzarbeit und im
vergleich zu den usa wo in den letzten
drei monaten 41 millionen arbeitsplätze
verschwunden sind kann man sagen wir
haben es ja wirklich wacker geschlagen
das ist die größte wirtschaftliche und
soziale herausforderung unserer
generation aber arbeitsmarktpolitik
allein hilft durch der sache ja als
arbeitsminister wir brauchen
wirtschaftliches gestehen wir brauchen
kaufkraft investitionen und da ist
glaube ich gestern etwas gelungen was
mithilft die wirtschaft anzukurbeln
damit arbeitsplätze zu sichern
aber was auch dafür sorgt dass das land
langfristig moderner digitaler sozialer
und ökologischer und deshalb fand ich
das gestern ein gutes ergebnis
sie sagen sie können nicht jeden job
sichern
wie groß sind die sorgen wenn die
kurzarbeit ausläuft wird der herbst
beginnt der winter beginnt mit welchen
arbeitslosenzahlen müssen wir rechnen
also wir haben jetzt schon auch ein
anstieg an arbeitslosigkeit das ist ja
gestern vermeldet worden
wir sind jetzt bei 2,8 millionen
arbeitslosen in der statistik wir waren
mal bei knapp über zwei millionen
aber wichtig ist dass wir erstmal
millionen von arbeitsplätzen sichern und
da ist tatsächlich die kurzarbeit auch
internationalen europäische anerkannt
unsere stabilste brücke über ein tiefes
wirtschaftliches teil
wenn wir aber langfristig arbeitsplätze
sichern wollen dann muss es ja gelingen
die menschen aus der kurzarbeit wieder
ein richtiger arbeit zu bringen
und da muss man unternehmen helfen
gerade kleinen mittelständischen
unternehmen da ist viel gelungen auch an
hilfen die dazu führen dass zum beispiel
betriebskosten von unternehmen die
massive umsatzeinbrüche haben jetzt
nicht mehr als kredite sondern als
direkte hilfen da sind da ist es wichtig
die kaufkraft anzuregen die
mehrwertsteuersenkung ist ein starker
impuls der vor allen dingen
geringverdienern übrigens zugute kommt
auch der familienbonus bediente übrigens
nicht auf die grundsicherung
rechnungen werden hilft was glauben sie
was die menschen mit dem familienbonus
mit dem kinderbonus
am ende machen werden werden sie das
geld auch wirklich ausgeben oder
vielleicht auf die hohe kante legen um
zu sparen dann hilft es ja wieder nicht
mehr dem konsum ja weil diejenigen die
wir gezielt etwas das ist ja im
gegensatz zu einigen pasta so erzählt
wird nicht mit der gießkanne sondern es
ist so dass geringverdiener die ohnehin
knappe haushaltseinkommen haben oder
auch sozialleistungsempfänger das dann
einmalig zur verfügung haben
das ist damit zu rechnen dass das in die
nachfrage die kaufkraft in die
wirtschaftliche nachfrage geht
spitzenverdiener werden übrigens nicht
so wahnsinnig profitieren weil natürlich
da das über die steuer gekippt wird das
heißt alle die entweder kein einkommen
haben bis zu einem jahreseinkommen als
familie von 84.000 euro und das ist
oberen mittelstand würde ich mal sagen
werden davon profitieren und dann ist
auch damit zu rechnen dass das kaufkraft
an recht sie haben die
mehrwertsteuersenkung angesprochen warum
setzt sich da sicher dass das
tatsächlich am ende einen impuls gibt
und dass vielleicht unternehmen nicht
einfach sagen das geld behalten wir
lieber für uns und geben sie nicht an
die kunden weiter man muss ökonomisch
darauf setzen dass die unternehmen ja
ein interesse daran haben ihre produkte
zu verkaufen oder ihre dienstleistungen
anzubieten das heißt ich rechne damit
dass es da schon vielleicht nicht in
jedem einzelfall aber in vielen
bereichen auch rabatt aktionen geben
wird oder auch preissenkung weil die ein
interesse daran haben sozusagen nur geld
einzustreichen wieder umsätze zu
generieren
es ist auch gut dass ist zeitlich
befristet ist für ein halbes jahr
das heißt wir kriegen ziemlich schnellen
effekt für die kaufkraft und für die
nachfrage und das ist glaube ich auch
ein gutes signal für ein stück aufbruch
in diesem land also das ist ein gutes
paket zusätzlich wie ich sagen das gut
ist dass unsere städte und gemeinden das
geld haben zu investieren das nützt auch
dem lokalen handwerk und damit
arbeitsplätze aber sorgt vor einigen
dafür dass wir unsere schulen wieder in
ordnung bringen können und modernisieren
können das heißt wir investieren und wir
modernisieren das land auch oder wie
olaf scholz ist gesagt hat mit
wohnungskrise mit wumms aus der käse
dennoch machen sich viele viele menschen
sorgen um ihren arbeitsplatz was sagen
sie
dem familienvater der vielleicht jetzt
noch einen job hat der sich aber groß
sorgen macht dass er diesen job im
winter vielleicht nicht mehr hat was
sollte man jetzt tun
ich sage ganz ernsthaft wir stand noch
nie vor einer so tiefen wirtschaftlichen
herausforderungen wie jetzt
und ich wiederhole ich kann als deutsche
arbeitsminister nicht für jeden
arbeitsplatz in einer marktwirtschaft
garantieren das wäre nicht redlich aber
ich bin mir sicher dass die maßnahmen
die wir jetzt schon ergriffen haben und
die jetzt seit gestern auf dem weg sind
dazu führen würden dass für die
wirtschaft in deutschland wieder in gang
bringen und damit arbeitsplätze sichern
und vielleicht sogar auch neue
zukunftsfähige arbeitsplätze schaffen
denn das ist ja wichtig dass wir jetzt
aus gronau auch eine lehre ziehen dass
wir das land insgesamt auch für die 20er
jahre vorbereiten schließen sie aus dass
es zu massenarbeitslosigkeit kommen kann
wie zum beispiel wie einen und 2003 über
fünf millionen arbeitslose ich glaube
dass wir die richtigen instrumente haben
die rückkehr von massenarbeitslosigkeit
als geisel die wir lange in deutschland
erlebt haben zu verhindern
dabei hilft das für eine robuste
wirtschaft haben nach wie vor das wir
qualifizierte arbeitnehmende aber nehmer
haben dass wir übrigens jetzt wie gesagt
auch was für ausbildung tun ich will
darauf hinweisen dass gestern auch
beschlossen wurde dass für die
unternehmen vor allem kleine und
mittelständische die weiterhin viel
ausbilden oder zusätzlich ausbilden dass
auch eine ausbildungs prämie geben wird
also das sind eine ganze fülle von
maßnahmen die helfen dass wir gut durch
diese zeit kommen und dass wir stark aus
der krise kommen wenn wir jetzt das
gesamtpaket anschauen da ist ein
wahnsinns betrag jetzt in juristische
130 milliarden
wenn das alles nicht funktioniert haben
wir noch geld in der hinterhand oder
war's das jetzt also es sind schon
gigantische beträge ich sage es nochmal
aber muss sich die alternativen angucken
in einer krise rein zu sparen heißt sie
schlimmer zu machen
das sagen alle ökonomen übrigens
inzwischen von rechts bis links jetzt
ist die zeit für kaufkraft und
investitionen und ich bin mir sicher
dass es gelingt es gibt restrisiken das
muss man immer sagen das hat mit
weltwirtschaftlichen entwicklung zu tun
die wir nicht allein in der hand haben
auch wenn deutschland europa ansteht
mitziehen würden wie auch in europa
maßnahmen treffen
und es gibt natürlich immer wieder die
gefahr dass ein aufkommen der pandemie
eine zweite welle
uns zurückwerfen kann das müssen wir
vermeiden deshalb sind solche
verhaltensweisen wie auf dem
landwehrkanal in berlin auch nicht
tolerabel das gefährdet das leib und das
leben von menschen ist auch zynisch
gegenüber den im gesundheitswesen das
sollte man dagegen tun hätte die polizei
früher eingreifen und ich glaube das ist
wichtig ist auf die gefahren hinzuweisen
und die gute nachricht ist ja dass die
allermeisten menschen in deutschland
sich hoch vernünftig verhalten und
deshalb mein motto ist von besserem
beispiel lernt man mehr als von
abschreckenden aber wo es abschreckende
gibt da muss man ein deutliches wort
sprechen oder zum beispiel wird das in
der fleischindustrie auch erlebt haben
mit gezielt maßnahmen durchgreifen
abschlussfrage arbeitsminister in der
diskussion die restaurants und bars in
vielen bundesländern dürfen sie maximal
bis 23 uhr eröffnen wann wird das wieder
möglich sein das kann ich ihnen nicht
sagen es liegt auch in der hand der
bundesländer das muss muss mit dem
infektionsgeschehen übereinstimmen
es gilt ja für die restaurants jetzt
kurz danach wieder aufmachen können nach
wie vor dass es auch regeln gibt und wir
haben auch erlebt wie notwendig die sind
rolle ob sie kommen aus ostfriesland das
was da passiert ist nicht während des
laufenden betriebs am abend davor ist
ein warnendes beispiel
wir müssen aufpassen dass wir den umgang
finden mit dieser pandemie die ja noch
länger geht es zu leben und dann stück
für stück wirtschaftlich auch wieder
nach vorne kommen arbeitsschutz ist da
zum beispiel ganz wichtig also ich kann
ihnen keine genaue prognose machen man
muss ein bisschen aufpassen dass man wie
gesagt sich nicht in falscher sicherheit
abend so eine hinter die töchter tut
dass man leichtsinnig wird und wir
spielverhältnisse bekommt also es wird
uns noch länger tatsächlich begleiten
auch wenn ich mit ihnen gern monsheimer
in anderen zeiten gern spät abends auch
mal wieder ein bier trinken würden herr
minister das werden wir tun herzlichen
dank und für den besuch und für das
interview
ich danke ihnen